- Who are you scared
to fail in front of?
The reason so many of you are
not doing what you wanna do
is you're scared
to fail in something.
You're scared that your
brother will judge you,
your wife, your girlfriend,
your husband,
and most scary,
your mom or your dad.
You need to eliminate
that, and/or own that fear,
and put yourself in
a position to succeed.
Because with all of this,
with all of this, we are
now in the greatest era.
For the first time ever,
with no fucking money,
with no god damn connections,
this can put you on the map,
if you're good enough.
If you are good
enough to be up here,
to make bling bling,
if you are good enough,
nobody's stopping you.
Not fucking Donald Trump, not
the fucking Russians, nobody.
(audience applause)
If you are a minority,
if you are a female,
if you are transgender,
if you're a fucking alien,
the market doesn't give a fuck.
If you make the
best shit, you will win.
Do you know how sucky it was
to be a nerd 20 years ago?
But now the market is
rewarding fucking nerds,
and now they're rock stars.
Clap it up if you're
a fucking nerd.
(audience applause and cheers)
The best part about that
was some dude
was clapping for it,
and I said, "Clap if
you're a fucking nerd,"
and he was like...
That's awesome.
(upbeat music)